an oscar-winning Dame's high octane
dream a world famous driver subtle Cameo
and what's cardi B doing bailing out Vin
Diesel here's everything you missed in
the Fast and Furious films
The Fast and Furious franchise has come
a long way since its debut in 2001. the
story in the first film The Fast and the
Furious comes from humble beginnings as
it follows the Journey of undercover cop
Brian O'Connor played by the late great
Paul Walker the plot details how Brian
infiltrates a group of competitive
Street Racers run by Vin Diesel's
character Dominic Toretto better known
as Dom for the most part things seem to
be going well for the young LAPD officer
aside from the fact that Dom's
right-hand man Vince mistrusts Brian he
clocks him as a cop right away Brian
runs into further complications when he
forms a true bond with dom and begins
developing feelings for his new friend's
younger sister Mia when Brian comes to
stop Dom and his crew from a car theft
gone wrong he helps rescue Vince who's
trapped on a truck unfortunately Vince
gets caught up in a wire that's cutting
into his arm luckily Brian is able to
save him and when Vince returns to the
franchise in Fast Five the scars from
that ordeal are present on his arm this
small detail goes a long way to help
encourage sense of consistency in a
franchise that doesn't always have the
best continuity are you serious right
now
by the end of The Fast and Furious Brian
has put his career in Jeopardy by
helping out Dom and his crew he
ultimately lets Dom go in order to stop
him from getting arrested audiences
learn in the next film Too Fast Too
Furious that this decision leads to
Brian losing his job as an LAPD officer
Fast and Furious 6 really amps up the
change of Direction in the franchise The
Familiar crew of Street Racers is now
turned into the only hope to stop a
criminal organization run by Owen Shaw
played by Luke Evans Dwayne Johnson's
character Diplomatic Security Service
agent Hobbs who once hunted Domino's
crew has now turned to them for help in
assisting with the other crew's arrest
according to Hobbes the crew is similar
to Doms and even Enlisted the help of
Dom's old girlfriend Letty who was
presumed dead by the end of the film all
is well for the Furious family Hobbs has
granted the entire crew pardons from the
US government allowing them to return to
the home where the franchise first began
lettius joined their team once more and
while she still suffers from memory loss
she and Dom are back together at the end
of the film Tyrese Gibson's character
Pierce has a brief exchange with Hobbes
when he appears at their barbecue
hey Mia you better hide your baby oil
I'm just playing you better hide that
big ass forehead I was just joking as it
turns out Hobbs crack at Pierce was
improvised by Johnson the scene was kept
in the Final Cut due to its hilarious
timing
it's no secret that Dwayne Johnson is
one of the hardest working entertainers
in the business in fact according to
Forbes he was one of the highest paid
actors in 2022 due to his roles in the
Furious franchise Black Adam and red
notice to name a few however before he
made a name for himself in Hollywood
Johnson made waves with his wrestling
Persona the rock it seems as though
professional wrestling is a family
business for Johnson as his father Rocky
was a famous Canadian wrestler similarly
his eldest daughter Simone has recently
announced that she'll be following in
her family's famous footsteps she's
debuted her wrestling name to be Ava
rake according to TMZ at the beginning
of Furious 7 audiences are introduced to
the latest threat to the Furious family
owenshaw's older brother Deckard Shaw
Shaw is out for vengeance after Hobbes
Dom and his crew put a stop to his
brother's activities placing Owen in a
coma in the process Shaw and Hobbs
engage in an epic fight when Shaw breaks
into the Diplomatic Security Service or
DSS office in Los Angeles during the
fight Johnson shows that she's retained
many of his hand-to-hand combat skills
from his previous career longtime fans
of the rock might even recognize when he
uses his classic finisher The Rock
Bottom against Shaw a detail surely
included as a nod to those who followed
the Entertainer since his early days
The Fast and Furious spin-off film Hobbs
and Shaw digs deeper into the shaw
family's Story the movie introduces the
character hadisha the younger sister of
Deckard and Owen she is an MI6 field
agent that has been relentlessly hunted
by terrorist Brixton lore however before
Hobbes learns any of this he spends some
time interrogating her as he believes
that she's a criminal at the end of his
interrogation he quotes the German
philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche there's
more wisdom in your body than in your
deepest philosophies let me guess Bruce
Lee no nietzsa
this is much to the surprise of Hattie
who had assumed that he was not
enlightened enough to discuss such a
celebrated intellectual however the joke
is clearly on her this might have seemed
like it was a tool used in order to give
Hattie and Hobbs some sexual attention
but there's a smaller detail that
foreshadows his interest in Nietzsche
the beginning of the film outlines the
morning routine that Hobbs goes through
in contrast with Shaw one moment
showcases the two making breakfast which
has a blink and you miss it moment Hobbs
is making eggs in a bowl where audiences
can see a copy of the book The portable
Nietzsche next to his stove the film
already told us that he's a niche effect
but it was only visible to those who
were paying attention to those seemingly
minute details
good
I'm impressed F9 was released in 2021
and saw the return of director Justin
Lin to the franchise currently Lin has
directed a total of five Furious films
The Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
Fast and Furious Fast Five Fast and
Furious 6 and F9 the story in F9 doubles
down on the core concept of family
within the franchise as it's revealed
that Dom and Mia have a brother that has
up until this point never been mentioned
their brother Jacob Toretto is played by
John Cena he's estranged from his family
after Dom discovers that he's partially
responsible for the death of their
father years later Jacob returns for
revenge against Dom as he's become a
renowned criminal working as a thief
assassin and high performance driver the
start of the film uses an older logo for
Universal Studios in the film's
commentary Lin details that this was an
intentional decision made on his part he
points out that the film begins with a
flashback to Dom's father's death in
1989 to provide context for the trip
boys relationship in the original the
fast and the furious Dom recounts how he
physically beat the man responsible for
his father's death in F9 we also see a
flashback of the assault in the
commentary Lin explained the choice of
going with an older logo was because I
wanted it to sync up with this flashback
to start
F9 brings Helen mirren's return to the
main Furious franchise after her
starring role in Hobson Shaw she
portrays the shaw siblings Deckard Owen
and presumably Hattie's mother Queenie
when Queenie is first introduced
audiences see that being a criminal
seems to run in the Shah family as she's
shown attempting to steal a necklace
when Dom approaches her she provides him
with information on his brother Jacob
treado's location during their
conversation Queenie has shown driving
recklessly through the Streets of London
as street racing is the origin of the
Furious franchise this decision was
likely made to keep in the tradition of
being too fast and Too Furious however
it was also a special request made by
the actress herself according to Yahoo
entertainment mirin shared my great
ambition is to be in a fast and furious
movie I so want to be a mad driver in a
fast and furious movie my claim to fame
is I always do my own driving I was on
Top Gear and I did my lap in a very good
time
rapper cardi B appears in a small guest
role in F9 as Lisa a woman who shares
history with dom her character rescues
him from being arrested by posing as a
police officer and provides him with the
key to his freedom once they're put in
the back of a policeman while her
connection to Dom may have seemed random
At first she does have a seemingly
throwaway line that holds hidden weight
to who her character is in the film she
says that if it wasn't for Dom she would
still be stealing gas this is a direct
connection to Dom Letty and Hans time
living in the Dominican Republic in the
fourth film of the franchise Fast and
Furious those three characters live in
the Dominican stealing gas to make a
living their time here takes place after
the events of the first pill when Brian
lets Dom go rather than have him
arrested as he and Letty become wanted
criminals they leave the states and
seemingly build a different crew clearly
Lisa was part of that crew for a short
time according to E.T diesel revealed
that cardi B's character will return for
the series 10th installment and that she
will be depended on even more discussing
lace's future in the franchise F9
director Justin Lin stated she's
actually really embedded into the
overall Universe she's been around for a
long time and this is just the first
time we are seeing her so I'm really
excited to explore that character of her
the timeline in the Furious franchise
can get a little murky although the Fast
and the Furious Tokyo Drift is the third
film to have been released in the
franchise it actually takes place as the
sixth in the timeline this is because
Sun Kang's character Han is introduced
and seemingly killed in Tokyo Drift at
the end of the film Dom appears for a
race to honor the friend he thought he
lost at the time Dom's appearance was a
big deal as this marked the return of
Vin Diesel to the Furious franchise as
the Furious films continued throughout
the years it's shown that Deckard Shaw
is responsible for Han's death in
retaliation for what Dom's crew did to
his brother owenshaw in Fast and Furious
6. but wait there's more the plot gets
even thicker when it's revealed that Han
didn't actually die instead he went into
hiding in order to protect a little girl
while the story of Han is a confusing
one there's a small but entertaining
detail about his name that we can't get
out of our heads in Furious 7 it's
revealed that his full name is actually
Han Solo a clever nod to Harrison Ford's
iconic Star Wars character Han Solo
however director Justin Lin later
revealed on Twitter that this is
actually just an alias that Han uses and
that his full name Still Remains a
mystery
no reward is worth this
The Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
introduces drift racing into the
franchise up until this point the series
was all about street racing with a dash
of police drama for good measure Tokyo
Drift is also the only movie in the
franchise that does not follow Brian or
Dominic instead an entirely new cast
gets introduced the film also made the
interesting choice to have most of the
characters be high school students
rather than adults taking part in
criminal activities in short it's
definitely the most divisive story to
come out of the Furious franchise a
small scene in the film that holds a lot
of weight is when audiences see a
fisherman watching Sean as he
embarrassingly attempts to drift for the
first time the fisherman is actually the
real life drift King keichi's Chia
according to an eagle-eyed Reddit fan
suchia helped popularize the art and
Toki driving which also features heavily
in the film surprisingly few
professional drivers have actually made
cameos in the Furious franchise so
suchia's appearance sets Tokyo Drift
even further apart from its counterparts
[Music]
foreign